for monday people traveling
internationally from england will need
to complete and carry a declaration to
travel form or risk a penalty
the department for transport has said
that travellers could be fined 200
pounds that they turn up at an airport
without the new form which must say why
they're permitted to travel
let's speak disguise either bennett
who's in the newsroom so why is this
penalty
being introduced now either yeah that's
a good question and i think one that
many people will be asking
now given that it's a full 40 days since
the measure was
first introduced by the home secretary
pretty patel and a full
two months since uh international travel
without a permitted reason was made
illegal in england
with the introduction of the third
national lockdown of course so the
timing is certainly
curious and a case of better late than
never i think for some
the government says it's to stamp out
illegal travel as i say
international travel is only allowed for
certain reasons from england things like
work volunteering education
funerals medical grounds and it means
that from monday
anyone traveling from england will need
to be in possession of one of these
forms stating the reason for their trips
it's a it's a pretty comprehensive form
three pages long
downloadable from the government's
website and if you don't have one
then you could be fined 200 pounds and
asked to return now
i think it probably will be dispensed
with once foreign holidays are allowed
again
which we know which we've been told is
no earlier than may 17th but i think it
is
worth just uh recalling at this point
matt hancock the health secretary's
comments
uh back in january in uh reference at
the time to vaccine passports but still
of note uh in this case when he said
we're not a papers carrying country
uh well it seems with this news we are
uh
increasingly so actually and just a note
on foreign holidays we've heard this
morning from cyprus that
they will be welcoming vaccinated brits
into their country from the beginning of
may which is
more than two weeks earlier than would
be allowed under the government
restrictions but from the point of view
of the cypriot government anyone with
two jabs can enter their country without
any restrictions no quarantine no
negative tests and with other countries
uh
suggesting that they are keen to head in
that direction too greece
portugal we've heard of today as well
then it looks like if you are going to
go on holiday this
this summer then there may well be quite
a lot of paperwork with it